Hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, yo, was geht ab? Hab dich heut gesehen in der Stadt, es sah gut aus, kommst du mir da raus, dann zählen wir uns zusammen, das Podcast-UFO-Rein! Hey, herzlich willkommen und vielen Dank für dieses fantastische Intro von Annabelle, großartig. Hallo und herzlich willkommen zu einer neuen Folge Das Podcast-UFO mit mir, Stefan Tietze und dir, Florin Dienbügel. Wir freuen uns sehr, wieder zurück zu sein. Ich finde es sehr schön, ganz sehr gemütliche Folgen. Du hast die Jacke gleich angelassen, das finde ich gut, das sagt nicht, ich habe keinen Bock auf diese Folge, das wird eine Express-Folge, ich bin hier gleich wieder raus. Nee, das sagt mir, du willst warm gehalten werden und es ist draußen kühl geworden. Das ist eine soziale Exit-Strategie, generell die Jacke anlassen einfach. Wenn du eingeladen bist bei Freunden, schöner Rummikub-Abend, du kommst da hin, du lässt die Jacke an, weil du den Leuten... den Rucksack auf den Schoß. Du stellst den Rucksack gar nicht, das ist nämlich der grösste Fehler, den man macht. Die meisten stellen den Rucksack erstmal auf den Boden. Das sagt, ich plane hier mindestens zehn Minuten zu bleiben. Verloren. Den Rucksack, das fand ich immer damals lustig, manche Schüler, oft waren es bei uns die Schülerinnen, die dann einfach ihre Tasche die ganze Zeit auf den Schoß gelassen haben. Und der Lehrer muss auch sagen, Leute, wir haben ein bisschen was vor heute, wir wollen eine dreiviertel Stunde lang Unterricht machen. Macht es euch bequem. Schuhe anlassen, Jacke anlassen, Mütze auf, Handschuhe an, einfach hinsetzen und sagen, so, wer würfelt zuerst? Lass ich die Vorspeise schon oder was? Ja, und jeder, der dabei ist, weiß einfach, du musst gleich weg, du musst gleich los, niemand weiß wohin. Ich bin ein bisschen krank tatsächlich, war diese Woche krank, ich bin sehr selten krank, weil ich einen eisernen Wehen habe. Und tatsächlich, Stefan T., ich muss dir beglückwünschen und vielleicht ist das eine neue Phase in deinem Leben. Du bist Influencer. Du bist Influencer, denn... Influencer. Was habe ich mir gekauft? Ich bin Influencer-Influencer. Was habe ich mir geholt? Du hast in der Kältungsbar gekauft. Ich habe mir natürlich in der Kältungsbar. Ich habe mir einen Erkältungsbad. Aber von Kneipp auch das Gute? Ich weiß nicht, ob es von Kneipp war, aber ich habe mir einen Erkältungsbad geholt. Ich dachte mir, Stefan T. hat mir was empfohlen und das ist so ein sportlicher, galanter, agiler Mensch. Ja. Muss ich mir holen, war schön bei Rossmann, hat mir schön einen Erkältungsbad geholt. Fantastisch, aber ich war erstaunt, weil da stand drauf, man darf nur alle zwei
Tage ein Erkältungsbad nehmen.
Also nicht jeden Tag.
Übertreibst nicht, don't get used to it.
Wo ich mir dachte so, wow, wie sieht eine Überdosis
Erkältungsbad aus?
Du bist zu entspannt, du kannst im Straßenverkehr
einschlafen. Ja, ich meine, es gibt
manche Sachen, da verstehe ich Überdosis,
keine Ahnung, Schmerzmittel oder so, da versteht man,
okay, die sind krass, zu wenige
sind okay, zu viele sind hart, aber dann gibt es
manche Sachen, wo Überdosis einfach Äpfel
Vielen Dank. Sachen, da verstehe ich Überdosis, irgendwie, keine Ahnung, Schmerzmittel oder so, da versteht man, okay, die sind krass, zu wenig sind okay, zu viele sind hart, aber dann gibt es manche Sachen, wo Überdosis einfach keinen Sinn ergeben. Äpfel, Äpfel, macht keinen Sinn. Es ist Vitamine, okay, irgendwann ist dein Körper genug Vitamine, aber mehr tun nicht weh. Es sind nicht vielleicht so Salze, die Öle aus deiner Haut ziehen. Das sind Salze, die Öle aus deiner Haut ziehen. Okay, gut, sagen wir, ich hab ab Mitte des Satzes war reine Impro, aber, aber, nee, das sind eigentlich Öle, die Salze aus deiner Haut ziehen, Herr Tietze. Ich glaube, es sind Salze, die gewisse Fette aus meiner Haut ziehen, dann tritt die Haut aus. Aber Fette sind doch Öle. Ja, das sag ich ja, du hast es gerade mit anderen Worten ausgetauscht. Aber Öle fügen Salz in die Haut ein. Ich sag Salze. Ne, ich sage, Salze sind in dem Erkältungsbad drin, die Öle aus meinen. Ich bleib dabei, Flo und Team, ich möchte das gerade auch reinloggen. Ich weiß nicht, warum Sie mir hier... Na gut. Sie haben gesagt A, B, C oder D. Na gut. Meine Antwort ist B. Wir loggen es ein, leider falsch. Leider falsch, leider falsch. Es war C, Scooby-Doo. Und ich habe dann tatsächlich, aber ich dachte mir, ich gehe all in, weil ich habe nie das Gefühl, also ich habe generell, ich glaube, es gibt vier Arten von Menschen, und zwar, wenn es um Anweisungstexte geht. Und die sagen dann so, und zwei, zehn, Knoblauch. Und bei mir immer in meinem Kopf, ach, drei, mach mehr draus. So wie es das als Tipps anzunehmen, von jedem, der stirbt vor dir. Hoch oder Kopf jetzt auch, okay, ich bin gespannt, was jetzt kommt. Und so dachte ich mir auch, bei dem Erkennungsbad, da stand dann zwei Kappen und ich dachte mir, neunzehn, wir bauen einfach vier rein. wirklich, das war so formuliert und ich weiß nicht, ob das Placebo ist, ob das clever ist, da standen wirklich maximal zwei Kappen und 15 bis 20 Minuten Bad nehmen. Ja, wir auch. Und ich denke mir immer so, ein Bad ist bei mir mindestens eineinhalb Stunden, nur ich dachte mir, ich gehe all in, aber ich glaube, das ist eine Placebo-Taktik. Weil alles, was man. Weil alles, was eine Wirkung hat, hat ja mehr Wirkung, wenn man denkt, es hat eine Wirkung. Und wenn da draufsteht, auf gar keinen Fall mehr als zwei Kappen nehmen, dann denkt man, okay. Doch, mehr als zwei Kappen. Gar keinen Fall trinken, doch trinkst du. Ja, aber dann denkt man, es wirkt stark und dadurch wirkt es dann auch besser. Insgesamt, ich weiß nicht, ob es was gebracht hat. Es riecht ganz angenehm, es ist nett, man hat was zu tun, man hat was in die Wanne zu gießen. Ja, das stimmt. Wobei ich muss sagen, da stand bei mir auch langanhaltender Schaum und ich weiß nicht, was ist die Definition, also wann der Verbraucherschutz sagt, das was auf der Verpackung steht ist falsch, aber ich würde sagen, zwei Minuten ist nicht langanhaltender Schaum. Ich glaube, da gibt es keine DIN-Norm für Schaum. Wobei meine Wanne ist auch nicht dafür gemacht, um Schaum zu erzeugen. Ich will es kochend heiß haben und dann kommt nicht, es kommt keine, es kommt nicht so viel Druck auf aus dem Wasserhahn, dass man sagt, okay, das ist eine schaumfreundliche Umgebung. Also wenn ich jetzt, wenn ich ganz heiß mache, kommt wenig Wasser raus bei mir. Aber hat das was mit Schaum zu tun, wie stark der Strahl ist? Ja, du musst ja. Starker Strahl, viel Schaum. Starker Strahl, schaucher Schaum. Das ist die alte Regel. Klar, weil ich glaube schon auf eine Art. Du meinst, es ist wie Kohlensäure, wenn man die Flasche Cola stark schüttelt, dann hat man viel Schaum. Angenommen, du lässt das Bad volllaufen. Es ist glasklar, das Wasser. Und dann machst du den Badezusatz rein, dann passiert nichts. Dann hast du keinen Schaum. Der Schaum entsteht ja dadurch, dass Luft im Wasser ist, die Luft einschliessen, diese Lauge oder was auch immer, das, was die Öle aus deiner Haut zieht halt. Das schließt ja die Luft ein, dann so bleiben dann Blasen, schon noch was damit zu tun. Aber zieht die Luft nicht die Salze aus den Ölen? Das ist ein ganz anderes Thema. Das kannst du in meinem Buch noch nachlesen, weswegen ich heute in der Sendung bin. Ich glaube, weil der Schaum entsteht ja auch da, wo das Wasser aufs Wasser trifft, weißt du? Weil ich bin eigentlich mittlerweile sehr schaumskeptisch ausgelegt und ich habe eigentlich gar keinen Bock auf Schaum, weil für mich ist Baden auch ein sehr akustisches Erlebnis. Ich höre immer Musik und freue mich.
Und wenn das kontinuierliche Krrrrrr, das ist einfach so, jedes Bläschen des Platz macht so einen Todesschreien und du hast wirklich deine Millionen, aah, die ganze Zeit. Und es ist wirklich so, wenn du mal wirklich die Musik ausmacht und alleine in einem Raum mit einer Badewanne mit Schaum stehst, dieses Geräusch, es ist so ein bisschen wie Speck in einer Pfanne, was ganz geil ist, dann kriegst du Hunger und dann ist, du bist so ein bisschen zwischendrin, das ist schwierig. Ich habe ja so ein Brett, ein Holzbrett, um dann mein Laptop draufzustellen, um Serie zu gucken, und das ist ein Problem, wenn der Schaum zu hoch wird, kommt der aus dem Brett wieder raus, weil das ist wie so ein Gitter und dann frisst sich der Schaum in den Laptop, was glaube ich nicht gut ist. Das ist aber ein Konstruktionsfehler, so ein Brett sollte keine Löcher haben. Ja klar, Wasser muss ja abfließen, wenn da mal Wasser reinkommt und so. Ich glaube, das ist schon okay, es ist nicht so gut, wenn da viel Schaum drin ist, das sollte man nicht tun. Aber wie geht es dir denn insgesamt, also wie gehst du mit so einer Erkältung um? Ich tatsächlich, ich bin großer Anhänger der Placebo-Theorie und ich versuche, Krankheiten primär durch Willenskraft zu besiegen. Und vor allem dann dieses, da stand dann drauf, und das fand ich sehr niedlich, nach diesem auf gar keinen Fall mehr als zwei Deckel und auf gar keinen Fall länger als 20 Minuten und anschliessend ans Bad dick einwickeln.
Und ich dachte mir, da wickel ich mich richtig mit ein.
Aber das ist so ein Ding, da habe ich... Macht euch einen gemütlichen Abend, steht da drauf.
Macht euch einen gemütlichen Tag.
Lass es ruhig angehen.
Und wisst ihr was? Gute Besserung wünsche ich euch auch noch.
Und dann seid ihr auch Danke, Kanne.
Macht euch schön muckelig einfach.
Ich glaube, die Kanne bei Erkältungsbad ist mein bester Freund. Ja, so 20 Minuten lang ein Muckeln, du süsses Mäuschen, du süsses Mäuschen, du. Aber dann habe ich mal gehört, dass der Körper ja ein Arschloch ist und der schon mit seinen Kräften haushalten kann. Soll er mit was aushalten kann? Mit seinen Kräften, mit seinen Ölen. Der hat einen gewissen Vorrat Öl und der kann damit auch haushalten. Das heißt, wenn du jetzt vom Mammut angegriffen wirst, dann hört der schlagartig auf, krank zu sein, weil du kannst dann einfach nicht mehr krank sein. Wohingegen, wenn du vom Mammut weggelaufen bist und dich ausruhend hinlegst, dann sagt er, okay, cool, jetzt werde ich krank, weil jetzt kann ich krank werden. Und deswegen habe ich immer so Respekt davor, mich dann so hinzulegen und schal und einzuwickeln,
weil dann kann der Körper richtig loslegen.
Ich habe so ein bisschen dieses, man darf
nicht zum Stillstand kommen Theorie.
Das heißt, ich mache sofort weiter, ich versuche weiter zu arbeiten.
Die Theorie wäre jetzt, These, Sorge für Mammuts
in deinem Leben. Richtig, genau.
Geh zum Beispiel auf eine Podcast-Sofotour und
geh abends auf die Bühne, Stage Health, Adrenalin.
Sorge für einen konstanten Strom kleiner
handhabbarer Mammut.
Oder schieb dir einfach so einen Adrenalinspritz in deinen Körper.
Zum Beispiel.
Und guck mal, was passiert.
Weil ich glaube, viel Adrenalin sorgt dann, wobei ich glaube, es ist nur ein Aufschieben.
Ich glaube, ein Mammut, also wenn du dann zwei Wochen lang, das war eine wilde Zeit damals, zwei Wochen lang von einem Mammut weggelaufen bist, glaube ich, dass danach, also in der Zeit bist du kein gesund, weil du musst funktionieren, der Körper muss funktionieren, aber sobald das Mammut dann gesagt hat, okay, weißt du was, ich bin langsamer als der Mensch, ich höre einfach auf, dann kommt die Krankheit, glaube ich, wieder zurück. Genau wie Stage Health ist ja Adrenalin, was funktioniert in deinem Körper, und sobald du von der Bühne gehst, bist du wieder sterbenkrank oder Aspirin komplex. Aber jetzt zum Beispiel sowas wie Fieber, das ist ja keine direkte Auswirkung der Krankheit, sondern das ist was, das der Körper selber macht. Der Körper regelt ja selber die Temperatur hoch. Das ist ein bisschen Durchlüftung. Und dann geht es dir schlecht. Das heißt, wenn der Körper gar nicht dazu kommt, zu sagen, jetzt machen wir die Temperatur hoch, würde er einfach nie fiebern und vielleicht braucht es das Fieber gar nicht. Doch, Fieber tötet ja Bakterien ab. Ja, aber vielleicht sterben die auch so. Ja, vielleicht sterben die auch so. Ich meine, hat der Körper da eine wissenschaftliche Studie gemacht gegen Kontrollgruppen? Nee, der Körper macht einfach mal irgendwas. Wir gucken mal. So, wir schauen mal, und vielleicht stimmt das nicht. Wir ballern mal kurz hoch für zwei Grad mehr und alle rasten aus. Da fällt einem ja auch auf, wie fragil der menschliche Körper ja auch ist. So zwei Grad wärmer und man fühlt sich elendig. Einfach zwei Grad ist die Körpertemperatur angestiegen, wo man sagt, draußen ist jeden Tag mehrere verschiedene, zehn Grad Unterschiede an einem Tag. Und der Körper sagt bei zwei Grad, es ist tot. Ja, deswegen, ich habe versucht, durch meinen eisernen Willen die Krankheit zu besiegen. Ja, klappt ja gut. Und es klappt hervorragend. Mir geht's fantastisch. Und ich kann diese Strategie nur weiterziehen. Ich war so krank an dem einen Tag, ich habe mit keinem Menschen gesprochen, ausser mit dir, habe ich geschrieben, weil die ein Geschäftskonto eröffnet haben. Oh. Interne Kleinigkeit. Und dann musste ich mich, dann gibt es ja diese Identifikationsverfahren, wo man mit Leuten skypen muss, mit der Webcam. Oh du hast gesagt, du musst das jetzt machen, es wäre besser, ich habe noch gefragt, muss ich das jetzt machen, ich habe auf so einen Wickel dich schön eingehofft, kam gar nichts zurück, zurückkam, ja, wäre schon gut, wenn es so schnell wie möglich passieren würde. Das ist der Ton in dem Blutdienst-Rep. Kein Smiley, gar nichts, kein Thermometer-Smiley, keine gute Besserung, Partyhut, gar nichts. Bei Finanzthemen bin ich eiskalt. Heißt, ich musste mich aus meinem Bett aufraffen, bin bewusstlos umgekippt, dann habe ich mich wieder aufgerafft, habe mich von dem Laptop geschleppt und habe dann mit dieser Frau telefoniert. Und man muss sagen, diese Menschen sind die angenehmsten Menschen der Welt. Ich glaube, ganz kurz, ich glaube, das Verfahren ist zu unbekannt, als dass man das voraussetzen kann. Wenn ihr irgendwo, das ist glaube ich bei Postidenten, macht das auch manchmal, Versicherungen machen das manchmal, um halt irgendeiner dubiosen Firma im Internet zu sagen, ja, das bin wirklich ich, ich kann diese Bankgeschäfte, diese Postgeschäfte, was auch immer oder Versicherungsdaten einsehen, muss man sich mit einem Reisepass oder einem Personalausweis vor die Webcam schnallen und muss dann mit einem Typen oder mit einer Frau sprechen und sagen, ja, das bin ich. Dann gibt es verschiedene, musst du verschiedene Winkel, die den Reisepass halten oder den Ausweis, damit die sehen, ja, die Sicherheitsmerkmale stimmen wir ein, er muss da teilweise deinen Namen verdecken, damit es nicht fälschbar ist und so. Das ist einfach eine Art und Weise, um sich vor einer Behörde zu identifizieren. Und diese Menschen, mit denen man dann da spricht, die sind einfach, die reden ja jeden Tag mit hunderttausenden Leuten vor dieser Webcam. Und das ist ein großes Center, man hört mit der Gründe, man hört mit anderen Leuten reden und so. Und ich hatte immer wahnsinnig viel Respekt davor, weil ich keine Lust habe, mit Leuten zu sprechen. Ich habe schon keine Lust, mit Leuten zu telefonieren. Am besten will ich alles irgendwie schriftlich lösen. Ich will nicht telefonieren und schon gar nicht jemanden sehen. Aber diese Menschen geben einem einfach das Gefühl, komplett egal zu sein. Einfach, die sind damit cool, die jetzt zu sehen, die interessieren sich nicht, wie du aussiehst, die interessieren sich für nichts. Das sind die angenehm, eigentlich sind das die besten Gesprächspartner der Welt. Und die haben vor allem schon alles gesehen. Die haben alles gesehen. Die haben einfach schon gesehen, wie ein 13-jähriger Hacker versucht, das Team zu betrachten. Ich hatte heute fünf Enthauptungen und du, ja, kein Problem. Das ist das Normalste der Welt, die haben alles gesehen in dem Leben, in jede Wohnung, in jedes Leben schon mal geschaut und die kennen dich. Wenn du da, wenn du erscheinst bei denen, ah okay, ja, ich bin Nina, Briggis hinter uns mässig, die sind entspannt. Und selbst, ich war so krank, sie hat kurz noch mal geguckt. Es kam kurz zu so einem, was, oh Gott, es kam kurz zu diesem Moment, dieses Zögern, dieses, du solltest das jetzt nicht tun. So krank war ich. Ja, ich wusste gar nicht, dass es sowas gibt und ich dachte, ich werde jetzt mit so einem Programm verbunden, wo ich dann einfach in so einem vorgegebenen Kasten meinen Ausweis hinhalten soll. Habe gar nicht damit gerechnet, dass der Person am anderen Ende ist. Und dann war erst mal so ein grießgrämiger alter Mann und dann habe ich so gesagt, hallo, hallo, hallo und er so, ich kann sie nicht hören. Ich kann sie nicht hören. Ich kann sie leider nicht hören. Und ich rede, rede und sage, warten Sie, warten Sie. und ja, ich kann Sie nicht hören. Ich kann Sie leider nicht hören. Und ich rede, rede und sage, warten Sie, warten Sie.
Und er, ich kann Sie nicht hören.
Bitte bringen Sie Ihr Mikrofon in Ordnung und rufen noch mal an.
Und er drückt auf so einen Knopf und ich bin weg.
Und ich dachte mir, ich habe versagt.
Ich habe versagt, habe es noch mal versucht.
Dann kam jemand, dann hat es auch funktioniert, aber es war aufregend.
Es ist so wirklich wirklich das ein,
wirklich der minimalste
Abstand zwischen Maschine und Mensch.
Diese Leute sind fast eine Maschine.
Sie müssen hören, wie der Name
ist, sie müssen sehen,
ob dein Name auf dem Pass steht.
Fast könnte das eine
Maschine machen. Aber deswegen
ist es auch so angenehm, weil sie sogar
keine Persönlichkeit haben. Nee, ist doch mutterhaft. Die interessieren sich auch gar nicht für dich. Es ist scheißegal, die stellen dir keine Fragen. Die sagen einfach nur, mach jetzt das, mach jetzt das und so. Ich werde mit so einer Person gerne zusammen. Oder sagen wir mal, befreundet. Mit so einer Person ins Kino gehen. Welchen Film willst du? Egal. Kannst du deinen Ausweis nochmal drehen? Ja, okay, ich dreh deinen Ausweis nochmal. Nie eine Frage stellt, nie ein, wie geht's dir, nie, warum guckst du so traurig, gar nichts. Bist du heute krank, du siehst heute furchtbar aus, du sollst mal wieder Sport machen, sowas kommt von dieser Person nicht. Diese Person vegetiert einfach nur vor sich hin. Aber ich frag mich, wie tolerant die sind, weil bei mir hat es ein bisschen gedauert, weil anscheinend, ich hatte einen Reisepass und da sind verschiedene so Kippmuskeln. Der Adler muss zu sehen sein. Da gibt es einen blauen Adler und noch einen Adler in deinem Profil, in deinem Passbild und so. Und bei einem, das hat bei mir einfach nicht geklappt. Ich habe vorhin zurückgeknickt und es hat nicht geklappt. Und ich dachte mir, wie tolerant sind die? Sagen die irgendwann so, ja, passt schon. Auch wenn du es einfach nicht hinkriegst, weil da muss einem das Licht genau einfallen und der Kamera, Webcam und so. Oder sagen die wirklich, ja, wir müssen leider davon ausgehen, dass ihr Reisepass gefälscht ist. Und ich drücke jetzt auf den Polizeiknopf jetzt. Wie viel Spielraum haben die? Nach dem vierten Sicherheitsmerkmal kann man davon ausgehen, dass das nächste auch noch funktioniert. Weil man denkt sich, ich würde doch nicht drei von vier fälschen. Eigentlich kann ich fälschen, dann fälscht ich dann nicht vier. Und bei dem D sage ich, aber diese rote Markierung da, oh, bauen wir die wirklich? Und er hat einfach gesagt so, führen Sie Ihre Hand mit gestreckten Fingern über Ihrem Gesicht vorbei. Ich muss immer wieder, ich muss immer den Satz nachsprechen, weil ich gar nicht in dem mentalen Zustand war. Führen Sie Ihre Was vor Ihrem Was her, um was zu tun? Ja, damit du kein Video bist, oder so eine, wie bei so Instagram-Filtern, hast du ja auch so ein Gesicht über deinem Gesicht. Aber wenn du die Hand über dazwischenführst, dann löst sich das auf. Und so. Es war aufregend, aber es war auch tatsächlich die erfüllendste soziale Interaktion für mich an dem Tag. Es war die einzige, ich habe mit niemandem gesprochen, ich habe an dem Tag nur mit der Person gesprochen. Und es war einfach so ein entspanntes Gespräch, wo keine Vorwürfe kommen, es kommt nichts, und danach ist sofort, und der Auftrag ist vorbei, und sie sagt, verabschiedet sich gar nicht mehr, einfach nur Verbindung weg, und man denkt sich, ja, mit jedem Menschen so sprechen. Und wir sind jetzt offiziell Geschäftsleute, ne? Ja, wir haben ein Geschäft gegründet. Wir haben eine GbR gegründet, mit dem vielleicht kreativsten Namen, den man haben kann. Ja, man muss sagen, ich dachte ja, irgendwann haben wir dann Einfluss auf unseren Namen und wir nennen uns irgendwie die Busselbärchen 30. Podcast Entertainment Industries, sowas. Ja, genau irgendwas Witziges oder irgendwie Wow Einhorn Productions. Nein, wir heißen Tietze und Will GbR. Und ich finde es ganz geil eigentlich, weil es so ein No-Bullshit-Name ist. Es klingt ein bisschen so, als ob wir so ein Familienunternehmen, Tietze und Sohn oder so, aber es klingt ein bisschen uncool. Wir können vor allem auch irgendwann den Kurs nochmal ändern. Und Anwälte werden. Also ja, wenn wir sagen, das Podcast läuft nicht mehr so gut, die T-Shirts verkaufen sich nicht, wir müssen jetzt nochmal Duftkerzen machen. Da geht es einfach, nee, wir haben die GbR jetzt auch wegen der Tour und wegen Merch und so funktioniert das einfach so besser. Und wir sind jetzt Geschäftsleute. Das heißt, wir haben jetzt ein Geschäftskonto, wir haben jetzt Anzüge an, wir sind jetzt richtig dabei. Wir sind jetzt Teil der deutschen Geschäftswelt. Und vielen Dank nochmal, dass du sich um die ganzen Bankkragen kümmert hast. Ich weiß nicht, ob das aufgefallen ist, aber das Erste, was ich gemacht habe, war, als ich mich angelockt habe, alle Adressen in meine Adressen umzuändern. Weil man hört ja Sätze von dir wie, ich mache Briefe generell nicht auf, ich mache keine Briefe auf, ich bin schon wieder umgezogen, ich bin obdachlos. Wirkliche Sätze hört man halt manchmal. Da will ich jetzt nicht. Und du wohnst nur zwei Tage die Woche hier. Ich habe jetzt erst mal so provisorisch, da habe ich so gemerkt, da kickt so eine Kontrollverlustangst total rein bei mir.
Ich weiß nicht, ob das eine Art ist, wie man mit seinem Geschäftspartner umgehen sollte, ehrlich gesagt. Dir ist schon klar, wenn wir uns jetzt erstreiten... Wir müssen sogar einen Vertrag aufsetzen, da ist es relativ gut geklärt, glaube ich, dass ich das machen darf. Ja, aber wie sieht es jetzt aus, wenn wir uns scheiden lassen, wenn wir jetzt sagen, wir wollen nicht mehr, wie läuft das dann? Wer kriegt dann das Kind?
Es steht sogar drin, wenn jemand von uns stirbt.
Den Vertrag, den wir beide, den du unterschrieben hast,
den du hoffentlich gelesen hast, steht da drin, was passiert,
wenn jemand von uns stirbt. Den Vertrag, den wir beide, den du unterschrieben hast, den du hoffentlich gelesen hast, steht da drin, was passiert, wenn jemand von uns stirbt. Was passiert dann? Ja, das hab ich jetzt auch nicht mehr im Kopf. Aber gut zu wissen, dass es abgeklärt ist. Das ist mir auch wichtig. Was dann im Detail erinnst du, ist mir auch scheißegal. Dann heisst die nur noch Tietze und EBL. Mir ist doch alles egal, wenn ich tot bin. Das ist doch ... Ich bin froh, dass es geklärt ist, für dich primär, damit du jetzt keiner nicht in dem Geld hinterherrennen musst, sondern du musst einfach sagen, hier ist es geklärt, ich kriege das ganze Geld. Aber mir ist doch egal, was passiert, wenn ich tot bin. Aber ist das Podcast-Ufels eine Tietze und Will GbR-Production eigentlich? Eine Tietze-Production, ja. Naja, Tietze und Will. Tietze steht oben, ganz vorne. Ich habe mich auch tatsächlich gefragt. Ich wusste auch nicht, wer das gemacht hat. Als ich das erste Mal gelesen habe Tiese und Will, dachte ich mir, naja, pass mal auf, Tiese und Will, steht der Coole an erster Stelle und zweiter Stelle. Schauen wir mal nach. Asterix und Obelix. Obelix ist cooler. Tim und Struppi. Struppi ist cooler. Bernard und Bianca. Absolut, Bibi und Tina. Tina ist cooler. Bibi ist offensichtlich cooler. Tina ist offensichtlich cooler. Bibi ist die mit den Zauberkräften. Überhaupt nicht. Heckler und Koch, ja, wir alle wissen, Koch ist die coole Sau. Von daher dachte ich, mach ich eigentlich sehr zufrieden. Ich wollte mich instinktiv beschweren, weil ich nicht als erstes stand. Ich glaube, das ist eine alphabetische Frage gewesen. Ich habe dann aber überlegt, eigentlich steht die coolere Person immer an zweiter Stelle. Ich bin jetzt kurz davor, mich zu beschweren, um ehrlich zu sein. Peanut Butter and Jelly? Immer Jelly? Immer Peanut Butter. Das ist der knallade Punkt. Das macht das Top Toys-A-Ars. Gut, meine beiden Späler sind vielleicht nicht so. Eins, zwei oder drei. Gut, das sind drei. Ja, du hast schon recht. Es ist nicht ganz so leicht, aber vielleicht müssen wir den Trend auch einfach umkehren. Elton vs. Simon. Ja. Elton. Auf meinen Flügen von Köln nach Berlin sehe ich gestalten. Das ist der absolute Wahnsinn. Simon Goseon habe ich jetzt getroffen. Schon wieder? Ja, dann Ingo Appelt habe ich getroffen. Das war ganz furchtbar. Aber was heißt getroffen? Hast du sie angestarrt von der einen Seite des Flugzeugs zur anderen, oder hast du sie wirklich getroffen? Nee, angestarrt. Aber ich finde es immer so spannend, weil, also ich weiß nicht, ob man das so sagen kann jetzt hier, was so cool ist. Aber Ingo Appelt sieht echt wahnsinnig fertig aus. So als ob da mal... Nee, das ist schon cool. Das ist geil. Mach dir da keine Sorgen. Ich mache mir so ein bisschen Sorgen gemacht. Das sieht richtig furchtbar aus. So, wo man sagt, da sind ja auch vielleicht andere Sachen im Spiel. Aber dann frage ich mich, hat man es als Comedian in Deutschland geschafft, dass man jetzt zu den Drogen greifen kann und so? Oder sollte man als deutscher Comedian nicht sagen, okay, ich sollte vielleicht eine Familie gründen, einfach ein normales Leben leben. Sollte man es in diesem Rockstar-Leben greifen, als deutscher Comedian? Das ist eine gute Frage. Ich finde nicht. Ich finde, man hat sich nicht das Hotel-Zerstören-Koks Monument geschaffen. Naja, ich sag mal so, ich habe letztens mit dem Gedanken gespielt, eine deutsche prominente Person in eine Sendung einzuladen. Und diese Person ist mittelmässig berühmt, sagen wir mal.
Und dann hat die Person abgesagt und dann dachte ich mir,
gibt's von der Person
Lookalike? Weil so für
Brad Pitt und George Clooney gibt's ja so
Lookalike-Agenturen.
Gibt's für, sagen wir mal, Ingo Appelt?
Gibt's da einen professionellen
Doppelgänger, Lookalike? So, und laden
sie Ingo Appelt auf ihre Party ein.
Und dann merken sie nach drei Minuten, dass es nicht wirklich Ingo Appelt ist
und führen die vielleicht unangenehmsten Gespräche in der Welt.
Das war vielleicht der lustigste gute Arbeitsketch,
der niemals realisiert wurde.
Wo wir Lookalike-Agentur erzählen wollten,
die Leute wie Herr Werner Heisenberg darstellen können.
Ja, genau.
Die einfach sehr speziell Special Interest Lookalikes haben. Sehr Special Interest Lookalikes und wir wollten vor allem, zum Beispiel war ein Lookalike, den man buchen konnte, Jürgen Habermas und wir wollten den echten Jürgen Habermas anfragen, der das Lookalike von Jürgen Habermas spielt. Und der echte Jürgen Habermas hat abgesagt. Ja, der echte hat abgesagt. Das muss man mal sagen. Der echte Jürgen Habermas, wo ich gerade in dem Zeitpunkt eine Vorlesung hatte, im Studium und so, der wollte ihn unbedingt einladen. Der hat auch reagiert und hat gesagt, nee, keiner gerne in die Zeit. Aber er ist generell für jeden Spaß zu haben. Nee, der hat doch genau im Gegenteil geschrieben, bitte sehen Sie von weiteren Anfragen ab. Wir rufen Sie nie wieder an, Stefan Dietzer. Der hat genau gesagt, falls Sie jetzt noch mal Nachfragen haben, ich werde immer Nein sagen. Aber daran ist letztendlich gescheitert, weil das wäre natürlich schon sehr lustig gewesen.
Aber ja, das stimmt. Und tatsächlich
für diese Person gab es keinen Doppelgänger.
Aber ich habe so eine deutsche Doppelgängeragentur gefunden
und da gibt es halt wirklich für
Leute Doppelgänger, wo du dir sagst,
da ist die echte Person wahrscheinlich billiger.
Aber es ist erstaunlich,
wofür es da alles gibt. Da gibt es dann...
Fährst du auch bald einen. Das habe ich mir nämlich auch gedacht.
Ich habe natürlich der klassische narzisstische Impuls generell nach sich selbst zu suchen, aber ich hätte so lustig gefunden, wenn der Florentin Wilder wäre. Ich könnte den Gag jetzt schon nicht mehr ertragen. Dann würde der heute auch nicht, würde heute gegenüber von mir sitzen, glaube ich. Das wäre doch der erste Gag. Ja, natürlich. Nach einer halben Folge sagst du dann so, jetzt muss ich doch mal nachfragen. Kurz, ganz kurz. Bist du der Doppelgänger? Aber es gibt da keinen, die deutsche Unterhaltungsindustrie ist nicht so weit, dass die Hierarchie klar von oben nach unten abgearbeitet wird. In der amerikanischen Unterhaltungsindustrie gibt es für die A-Lister alle Doppelgänger und dann geht es einfach die Liste nach unten. In der deutschen aber nicht, da kann man nicht sagen, es gibt keine Ahnung, den Thomas Gottschalk, es gibt den A-Lister, sondern es gibt so einzelne Bruchstückhafte und teilweise auch sprunghaft bis in die F-Liste hinein, wo dann ganz Jumbo Reinhardt Doppelgänger. Und wenn du denkst, ist nicht Jumbo Reinhardt Doppelgänger? Ist ja nicht Schreiner, Jumbo Schreiner. Jumbo Reinhardt.
Jumbo Reinhardt?
So bekannt sind die Leute, die aus Deutschland Doppelgänger haben.
Jumbo Schreiner.
Wirklich?
Jumbo Pizza, Jumbo Jet, Jumbo Schreiner.
Ach, tatsächlich, okay.
Aber er ist nur der drittbeliebte Jumbo bei Google.
Hinter Jumbo Jet und Jumbo Pizza. Ey, können wir so ein Google-Autocomplete-Interview mit Jumbo Reinhardt machen? Schreinhardt machen? Schreiner! Schreiner machen, der dann so sagt Jumbo. Aber guck mal. Der hat bei Traumschiff Surprise mitgemacht? Ja. Als was? Als dicker, lustiger Mann. Was glaubst du denn? In welcher Welt denn? In der Westernwelt? Ich glaube, in der Science-Fiction-Welt.
Aber ich bin mir nicht sicher, ich habe den Film einmal gesehen.
Aber da rufst du halt ein und sagst, sie hätte gern einen Doppelgänger von Jumbo Reinhardt und die so, sie meint Jumbo Schreider.
Sie meint Jansch Widerik.
Jaja, also ganz, ganz merkwürdige Welt. Das sind ganz, ganz merkwürdige Welt.
Jansch Widerik, Ayman Abdallah, Stefan Gödel.
Glaubst du, es gibt einen Lookalike von Ayman Abdallah und dann kann man sich Ayman Abdallah auf seine Party einladen? Ich meine, so für so Hipster-Band-Szenen-Partys. Warum macht Ayman Abdallah nicht nebenbei Geld als Lookalike von Ayman Abdallah? Warum sagt er nicht einfach, ich mache auch Lookalike Sachen von mir? Von mir und Will Smith, je nachdem. Das ist auch lustig, wir sind ein bisschen selbstreferiert, aber bei guter Arbeit kam mal ein Gastregisseur, der eins zu eins so aussah wie George Clooney. Der Sketch war nachher furchtbar, aber nur weil ich mich die ganze Sitzung lang nicht konzentrieren konnte, weil ich die ganze Zeit irgendwelche Bilder von George Clooney rausgusset habe, wo er aussieht, wie der Typ, der gerade neben uns in einer Sitzung satt und dir geschickt hat. Ja, ja, ich erinnere. Weil ich es nicht ertragen konnte, ist er ausser wie George Clooney. Ja, what else? Und der hat jetzt einen grossen Preis gewonnen. Ja? Einen deutschen Regiepreis oder so. Oder ist irgendwo so ein Filmfestival, Sundance oder so ein Scheiß, mit so einer Doku vertreten. So viel Verwirrung, wenn der dann da ankommt und eindenken, ist es George Clooney. Ich glaube, der ist wirklich bei Sundance als Dokuregisseur. Aber Sundance ist, wir wissen ja alle, dass es nicht das beste Filmfestival ist. Stimmt, es gibt bessere Filmfestival. Es gibt definitiv bessere Filmfestival. Aber ja, ich finde das sehr interessant. Ich glaube, da könnte man auch eine coole Serie drüber machen, über so eine Lookalike-Agentur. Und du hast dann so diesen einen, der nie weggeht und so. Ich finde es ja auch gut, bei Nathan4 You zum Beispiel, extrem empfehlenswerte Serie, die immer wieder den Bill Gates Look-alike Charakter haben, der dann immer als Einladung für Partys geholt wird. Wo du denkst, ich meine, egal wie gut der aussieht, er sieht nicht so aus wie Bill Gates. Er spricht auch nicht so gut wie sie. So what? Und er hält dann so einen Vortrag so, ja, damals war ein Computer so groß wie ein Raum. Und wir hätten uns vorstellen können, dass irgendwann jeder einen in seiner Tasche hat und alle denken sich so, oh mein Gott, wenn er so einen coole Insider aus der Microsoft-Geschichte hätte, ja, aber hat er ja nicht, weiss er ja nicht, also sehr frustrierend, aber es ist ein total interessantes Setting, wie du denkst, okay, ich gehe jetzt einfach rein, ich sehe ein bisschen aus wie Kylie Minogue, wenn man so mit beiden Augen zugedrückt und so aus der Entfernung und nicht mehr genau weiß, wie sie aussieht und seit zehn Jahren kein aktuelles Foto mehr, wie sie gesehen hat. Wenn es danach geht, sehe ich aus wie 50 Prozent aller deutschen Prominenten, wenn so viel ich irgendwelche Nachrichten bekomme wie, oh, der sieht genauso aus wie du, Typ mit Brille. Mittlerweile ist es nur noch Typ mit Brille, es ist nicht mal mehr, gar nichts muss stimmen. Hautfarbe ist egal, Haarfarbe ist egal.
Bei mir ist es Typ mit Bart.
Letztens jemand hätte er sieht genauso aus wie Florentin,
er hatte eine andere Haarfarbe, er hatte einen längeren Bart,
keine lockigen Haare, stockschwarz.
Und es ist einfach, vor allem selbst, wenn es Leute da draußen gibt,
die so ähnlich aussehen wie ich, es interessiert mich nicht so sehr.
Aber ich freue mich, dass sie an mich denken.
Wir haben letzte Woche eine Storyline weitergeführt, die, wie wir beide finden, eine Gesellschaft sehr wichtig ist und sehr relevant ist, nämlich ich bin AIDS-resistent. Müsst ihr da wieder eine Entschuldigungsrubrik machen? AIDS-resistent! Machen wir eine Entschuldigungsrubrik? Wir haben bei der DKMS angerufen, um herauszufinden, warum ich noch nicht angerufen wurde als älteresistenter Mensch.
Und in der Zwischenzeit wurde mir auf die Mailbox gesprochen. Aber es ist doch jetzt so, dass der erste, AIDS wurde erfolgreich geheilt als erstes Mal. Nein, so kann man das nicht formulieren, Blondin. Sondern? Ein Patient wurde geheilt, weil er meine Mutation implantiert hat. Ja, aber die Krankheit AIDS wurde bei diesem Patienten geheilt. Du hast gerade so gesprochen, als ob AIDS jetzt kein Thema mehr ist. Nee, okay, aber bei dem war es ja so, das Problem ist ja, dass es irgendwie super, dass die Ärzte nicht wussten, ob das klappt oder nicht, und der Patient hatte auch noch Krebs. Also da dachte man... Oh, wirklich? Ja, ich glaube, so war es. Der hatte sowohl Krebs als auch AIDS. Also muss man echt schon mal sagen. Auch ein Typ, der echt in die Scheiße gegriffen hat. Aber da haben die Ärzte dann gesagt, naja, man kann ja... Wann muss sich das ausrechnen, dass sie in dieser Kette Aids heilen konnten? Ich glaube, die Sache ist ja die, du kannst Aids, also jetzt wieder Tausendhalb wissen und ihr müsst uns nicht schreiben. Alle die Leute, die es interessiert, können auch auf eigene Faust recherchieren. Und es war ja so, dass man Aids auch einfach lange pausieren kann oder dass man nicht stirbt deswegen. Man kann auf Stopptaste drücken. Genau, man kann auf die Stopptaste drücken. Es wird nie wirklich geheilt, aber man kann die Effekte hinauszögern. Mit einem Erkältungsbad zum Beispiel. Genau. Wie gesagt, bis Halbwissen. Und das hat man oft gemacht. Und dann hat aber jemand die Idee, hey, wir können das auch heilen, ist aber riskant. Ja. Und wenn wir das versuchen, dann kann man, glaube ich, nicht mehr das Aufschieben machen. Und dann war eben einer da, der hatte Krebs, wo man sagt, gut, du wirst eh sterben. Lass uns doch jetzt bei dir bitte mal dieses Aids-Ding ausprobieren. Lass uns mal, so zwei Umschläge wurden ihm hingelegt. Möglichkeit eins oder die, jetzt ist es eh schon scheißegal, Möglichkeit zwei. Und dann, ja komm, jetzt ist es eh schon scheißegal, Möglichkeit zwei. Und dann, okay, wir versuchen mal was Abgefahrenes. Und sie haben dann gesagt, ja, sie haben völlig recht, bei mir ist es eh schon scheissegal, haben sie es nett ausgedrückt, Herr Arzt, machen wir. Herr Doktorarzt. Sie ist gemacht und AIDS wurde geheilt und die Ärzte jubeln und Champagnerflaschen knorren und der Patient wäre dessen so, ja, ich sterbe morgen, ja. Krebs auch noch, nee, schade, gut, okay, dann, aber da wurde Aids geheilt, wahrscheinlich alles falsch, aber egal, ich finde es eine interessante Geschichte, und Stefan T., und dann vor allem habe ich gehört, zehn Prozent aller Leute sind Aids-resistent. Nein, ein Prozent, ein Prozent aller Menschen, stimmt nicht, jeder Hundertste hat, nee, jeder Tausendste hat diese, guck doch mal nach, ist selten, ist fucking selten.
Ich dachte mir, Stefan erzählt mir seit Wochen hier irgendwie streckt sein Cape da, irgendwie Aidsman und sowas irgendwie. Hey, Aidsman, es gibt ein paar Aids, wie X-Men, es gibt nicht nur einen X-Men, es gibt mehrere Aids-Men, es gibt mehrere Aids-Men, okay? Ich habe nie gebraucht, ich werde der einzige. Ja gut. Aber es ist nicht jeder Zehnte, das ist völliger Bullshit. Jedenfalls die DKMS hat mein, also das ist ein Knochenmark-Spendeverein, das wird hier nicht ausgerübt, und die, also der Empfing hat einfach, eingetragener Knochenmark-Spendeverein. Ja, Knochenmark e.V. Da wird mal abends ein bisschen getrunken, am Wochenende wird Fußball geguckt und nebenbei wird ein bisschen Knochenmark gespendet. Richtig. Vereinsheim. Gekickert. So, und dann, ich habe angerufen und gefragt, warum rufen die mich nicht an? Wir wollten hier auch ein bisschen Awareness schaffen. Sie hat nur gefragt, wie sie uns behilftet sein kann. Ich werde noch mal anrufen, wenn wir irgendwann mal eher aufnehmen. Es geht jetzt immer so hin und her. Naja, aber ich bin jetzt zumindest bei einer Kölner Nummer. So, ich will jetzt nicht die Zentrale nehmen. Lass uns doch Thais da hinschicken. Die soll eine Reportage machen. Die soll einfach ein bisschen Knochenmark von dir mitnehmen. Die kriegt dann so ein bisschen... Nein, Thais kann nicht einfach Knochenmark von dir mitnehmen. Klar, die kann das, was die Leute in deiner Schule lernen. Die nimmt dir ein bisschen Rückenmark und hat dann irgendwie so ein Fläschchen Rückenmark und geht da hin und sagt, ich hab's, ihr könnt Aids ein. Was ist ein Rückenmark? Was ist ein Rückenmark? Ich will das gar nicht wissen, ich finde das so ekelhaft. Apropos Thais. Thais ist unsere festangestellte Schülerpraktikantin mittlerweile unbezahlt und sie kann und darf und ist aufgefordert, immer wieder coole Beiträge für uns zu schneiden oder rauszugehen und sich ihrem Journalismus zu frönen. Und ich bin echt gespannt, weil sie kam heute mit einem neuen Beitrag um die Ecke. Wir wissen noch nicht, worum es geht. Ich auch nicht. Wir können auch nicht gut anmoderieren jetzt, weil wir nicht wissen, was passiert. Auf jeden Fall hat Thais unterwegs für uns und hat recherchiert. Viel Spaß mit Thais on the Road, eine weitere Reportage aus der Welt von Thais. Viel Spaß. Angesichts des Fotobeginns in Düsseldorf habe ich mir nicht nehmen lassen, mein Meisterwerk, entstanden in Köln-Ehrenfeld, der Kunstwelt zu präsentieren.
Bei dem Kunstwerk handelt es sich um einen Schnappschuss von Florentin Will, worauf er, in ein Handy versunken, im Gang des Neomagazin-Flores steht.
Das Bild ist leicht unscharf oder wie ein Kunstleihe sagen würde, verwackelt.
Für meine Leidenschaft der Fotografie erhielt ich in meiner Vergangenheit schon die ein oder andere Rüge.
Nun werden wir hören, ob es sich gelohnt hat.
Ich habe hier ein eigenes Bild gemacht, das stellt die Abhängigkeit des Menschen von Social Media dar.
Wer hat jetzt diese Fotos gemacht? Die haben Sie gemacht?
Ja.
Okay, und jetzt soll ich sagen, ob das Kunst ist?
Das sind jetzt Fotos, die beiläufig gemacht worden sind, die ganz witzig sind, ganz originell, aber als Kunst würde ich das noch nicht bezeichnen. Alles kann Kunst sein, wenn es etwas bedeutet zu hören möchte. Ja, es kann auch in der Galerie sein. Ja, also findet es Kunst? Also was Kunst ist und was nicht, muss immer neu entschieden werden. Das kann man gar nicht so exakt sagen. Also das ist eine Sache, die wir immer wieder neu besprechen. Insofern würde ich nie sagen wollen, das ist Kunst oder das ist keine Kunst, sondern die Frage ist, was erzählt das Bild. Und wie du sagtest, es geht um Abhängigkeit von Social Media. Ich kennt, jeder sitzt im Zug und alle gucken in ihr Handy. Die Leute gehen durch den Park und genießen nicht die Natur, sondern schauen auf ihr Handy. Kriegen wir das jeden Tag natürlich vor Augen geführt, was es bedeutet, wie abhängig wir von den Bildern sind und von den Nachrichten, die dann in dem Handy gezeigt werden. Und hier der junge Mann, der da so läuft, ja, und während er läuft, er nimmt sich noch nicht mal die Ruhe, sich hinzusetzen, zu gucken, sondern während des Laufens, also multitaskingmässmäßig, guckt er gleichzeitig, was für eine neue Information reingekommen ist.
Und das ist natürlich sehr schön dargestellt, man sieht das sofort und auch dieses Verwackeln, dass wir hier so ein Verschwimmen haben,
merken wir, dass der ist in Bewegung, der ist dynamisch, hier verwischt irgendwas, ist das natürlich ganz spannend,
weil das sozusagen nochmal reflektiert, dass ja auch die Social Media, also dass die Informationen, die wir kommen, ganz schnelle Informationen sind und dass die im nächsten Moment vielleicht auch unwichtig geworden sind, also die verschwimmen, die verrutschen.
Und dann ist überhaupt die Frage, was ist scharf, was ist unscharf, was ist jetzt eigentlich deutlich und was ist undeutlich und wo müssen wir eigentlich genau hinschauen und wo ist eigentlich sozusagen die ganze Zeit nur Bewegung, zeigt das das Bild ganz schön. Und ich glaube, damit ist das super aktuell und somit immer auch wert, gezeigt zu werden und darüber nachzudenken. Ich finde, das ist ein gutes Bild, das ist vielleicht der erste Schritt oder vielleicht bin ich auch der nächste, der das schon, der zweite, der dritte, der das gesagt, wenn du daran glaubst und wenn du sagst, ich schaffe das, ich habe so viel zu erzählen, dann schaffst du das auch. Wie finden Sie, dass Tonspuren oder Tonaufnahmen auch Kunst sind? Die Kunst hat viele Ausdrucksmöglichkeiten, auch Tonspuren sind Kunst, ja. Dann würde ich dann kurz in den Podcast reinhören und sagen, ob Sie das eventuell als Kunst erfinden. War mein Traum die ganze Zeit, also waren sämtliche Gedanken des Tages halt verpackt in einer Welt. Und diese Welt hat mein Kopf entschieden, musste sein Wien, wo eine Glaskuppel drüber ist. Und dann war alles, alle anderen... Eher nicht. Erzählt mir jemand was. Wenn ich mich da auf diese Dinge einlasse, ist alles Kunst, was hier passiert um uns rum. So einfach ist es dann ja doch nicht. Bis zur nächsten großen Kunstausstellung schaffen wir es doch locker, uns in der Kunstlobby einen großen Namen zu machen, oder Florentin? Okay, die Frage ging an dich. Okay, ein bisschen abruptes Ende. Ja, auf jeden Fall. Ja, vielen Dank, Thais. Danke, Thais. Ein weiteres Audiofeature. Wir wollen natürlich, du wirst jetzt, sag ich mal, immer reifer in deiner Audiofeature-Kunst. Da kann man auch jetzt mal als zwei Leute, die dich auch als Mentoren verstehen gegenüber von dir, auch mal ein bisschen strenger sein. Wir, sag ich mal, die ersten Features und generell so die Regel ist, die ersten Male lässt man jemand Neues ausprobieren. Aber jetzt, wir müssen schon ein bisschen in die Kritik gehen, um dir auch ein bisschen Feedback zu geben. Es ist natürlich nicht ganz unproblematisch, ein Audio-Feature über ein Bild zu machen. In einem Podcast, in einem Audio-Medium. Der Hörer hat das Bild ja nicht vor sich. Du hast es natürlich erklärt, wie es aussieht, aber optimal ist es nicht. Ich nehme mal an, dass ihr das Bild euch irgendwo anschauen könnt, dass wir das posten werden mit der Folge. Um klarzumachen, dass es nicht geht, sollten wir das Bild auch nirgendwo mal posten. Das stimmt eigentlich, ja. Wir sollten das Bild eigentlich als Lehrstück für Thais, finde ich, ist es unsere Pflicht, es gerade nicht zu posten, um auch die Community mal aufzufordern, zu sagen, Thais, das ging so nicht. Ich habe mich ausgeschlossen gefühlt als Hörer, weil ich das Bild nicht gesehen habe. The medium is the message. Wie bereits wer gesagt hat. Richtig, ich dachte kurz, wer haben wir es. Und das heißt, dass man natürlich auch den Inhalt der Form anpassen muss. Und somit ist es natürlich schwierig, über visuelle Dinge in einem Podcast zu reden. Kann natürlich auch interessant sein. Der Zuschauer, der Hörer stellt sich das vor. Aber hier natürlich gute Arbeit, wie immer der Wind. Das ist so ein bisschen dein Nemesis. Das ist ein bisschen dein Ding, das ist so ein bisschen dein Erzfeind. Die unsaubere Tonaufnahme. Das ist die Achillessehne der Thais, ist wirklich der Wind. Aber ist auch windig im Moment, muss man schon noch sagen. So ein Bericht von so einer Handball-WM in der Halle und bei ihrem ... Wo man auch sagt, warum, wo bist du da gegangen? Wo Wo kommt der Wind her? Grandios auf jeden Fall. Ich finde das Thema, ich würde gerne die Kritik am Thema auch ein bisschen mal zum Ausdruck bringen, weil dieses ewige, ist das Kunst oder kann das weg, es hat man auch wirklich schon ein paar Mal gehabt. Und ich finde auch große Kritik an Circus Halligalli oder Lader Berlin, die es jetzt vor ein paar Wochen wieder gemacht haben, irgendwie eine Ausstellung Müll genannt haben, M-Y-L und nur Müll ausgestellt haben und das dann als Kunstwerk verkauft haben. Das ist ein bisschen lame. Vor allem weil die Kunstwelt das er selber macht. Also sowas wie, das wurde ja schon tausendmal, der Gag ist ja uralt, es gibt ja nichts Älteres als Dizzen-Gag. Den macht er selbst die Kunstwelt. Und das ist so postmodern, Kunst irgendwie so zu kritisieren, sehe ich den Sinn nicht mehr. Es ist sehr leicht, sich über diese Szene lustig zu machen. Das ist wirklich billig. Ich finde aber in dem Feature, die Interviewten haben da alle gut drauf geantwortet. Die waren alle gut. Von daher läuft das so ein bisschen ins Leere. Du hast die guten Interviewpartner gesucht und die guten Stipsel auch. Die haben wahrscheinlich auch alle ihr Einverständnis gegeben, dass es in dem Podcast läuft. Das ist ja natürlich auch gut. Das ist klar. Freut uns. Ja, vielen Dank. Und Thais bleibt weiter Bestandteil dieses Podcasts. Sie wird immer wieder Dinge für uns erspähen, sozusagen, raus in die Welt. Genau, und wird dabei, das ist unsere Garantie, als Mentoren immer besser. Und nie bezahlt. Und nie bezahlt. Die DKV-NS ist vielleicht das nächste Ziel ihrer investigativen Spürnase. DCM-DNV ist genau das nächste Ziel, da will ich mal wissen, was sie da genau machen. Aber wie geht es jetzt weiter? Die DCV-DNS hat geantwortet, wie sieht die nächste Riposte von Stefan T. aus? Ne, ich werde da mal, wenn wir eine Aufnahme machen, die mal vor 18 Uhr beginnt, können wir da ja einfach anrufen und mal mit denen sprechen. Uns geht es ja nicht darum, ein User hat nett geschrieben, dass wir denen die Zeit klauen und die wir bei Massagesesselsen und Hotlines anrufen sollen. Ich finde nicht, dass das vergleichbar ist, weil ich finde, man kann denen ja trotzdem Raum schenken. Und sie können es auch erklären, dass sie das nicht machen und was sie tun. Ich würde einfach mal gerne wissen, was sie da genau machen, warum ich noch nicht angerufen wurde und an wen ich mich wenden muss, vor allem, um die Welt von Aids zu befreien.
Ja.
Eigentlich jeder Aids-Tote ist zu viel ab jetzt.
Und du müsstest auf jede Beerdigung gehen und sagen, ja, hier bin ich.
Nee, ich finde vor allem, ab jetzt hat jemand Schuld.
Ich habe hier öffentlich gesagt, in einem öffentlichen Raum,
ich bin Aids-resistent, mit meinen Genen kann man Menschen retten. Ja, das hast du schon oft gesagt.
Alle Leute, die jetzt an Aids sterben, sind Leute, die jemand umgebracht hat, der nicht gehandelt hat und meine Mutation den eingefärscht hat. Ja, du musst aber deswegen trotzdem nicht wütende Bücher an die Familien der Zurückgebliebenen schicken. Die sind Mörder, Drecksmörder. Nicht unbedingt, nicht unbedingt, Stefan Dietze. Also willst du mir sagen, dass Familie Müller, den ich letzte Woche erst geschrieben habe, weil ihr Sohn seit mehreren Jahren an Aids litt und es verstorben ist und die nichts getan haben, mich nicht angerufen haben, den Podcast nicht mehr kannten, nicht schuld sind. Das ist aber nicht unbedingt deren Schuld. Und ich meine, du hättest den jetzt auch nicht vor ihrem Haus skandieren müssen, ich bin AIDS-resistent,
ich bin AIDS-resistent. Und ihr seid Mörder, ihr seid Mörder.
Und ihr seid Mörder und mich könnt ihr nicht
umbringen, ihr AIDS-Schweine. Das ist
natürlich ein bisschen der Umgang auch mit den
Hinterbliebenen ist natürlich
Forderung Fingerspitzengefühl.
Deswegen aber, äh, tatsächlich
es war sehr windig und
ein enormer Wind ging durch Köln.
Unglaublich. Ich finde ja, Wind ist ja meine Lieblings Naturkatastrophe, muss ich sagen. Von allen sagen, Überschwemmung. Ich war auch wie so eine Katze, weil es war am Wochenende sehr windig und ich hatte nichts zu tun. Und bin dann wie eine Katze von Fenster zu Fenster gestreunt, um rauszugucken, weil ich fand das ganz toll. Es ist grandios und vor allem, ich weiß, ich check ja Fenster nicht. Und ich habe immer Angst, dass Fenster irgendwann eingedrückt werden, weil die haben ja so eine große Fläche und sind eigentlich... Und du stellst die ganze Zeit erst dagegen gedrückt, von innen gegen die Hand gegen die Scheibe. Wie so ein Tellerdreher immer hier mal. Nicht meine Fenster, Wind! Nicht meine Fenster, nicht mit mir! Und bei mir kam sogar direkt die Feuerwehr. Weil die gesagt haben, ihre Fenster sind in Gefahr. Weil ich sie gerufen habe. Weil ein Stück entfernt von mir ist eine Baustelle und der Wind war ja am Wochenende und die Bauarbeit ist einfach heimgegangen am Wochenende, dachten sich, ja scheiß drauf, Hausbauzüge. Und Baustelle war weg. Baustelle ist jetzt in Hamburg. Baustelle, die Zäune wurden umgerissen, Baumaterial fliegt durch die Straße, macht alles kaputt, die Feuerwehr kommt und es ist so ein bisschen, die Feuerwehr denkt sich, ja, das ist ja nicht unsere Baustelle, was sollen wir hier machen, wir räumen doch jetzt nicht deren Scheiss auf, haben das aber dann abgesperrt, zum Halbmotiviert. Ja, Moment, aber die können nicht sagen, das ist nicht mein Feuer, das haben wir nicht verursacht. Die Feuerwehr hat glaube ich nicht die Macht zu sagen, wir sind dafür nicht schuld. Wenn dir jemand sagen müsste, ich räume den Dreck der anderen auf, dann die Feuerwehr. Naja, die sagen, sobald es brennt, sind wir dabei. Aber wenn die nur
ihr Zeug nicht gut festzurren
und es fliegt durch die Gegend.
Trotzdem fliegen wilde Kacheln durch die Strassen.
Ja, es war Kachelalarm.
Ich glaube, die haben dann erst mal angerufen und gesagt,
Entschuldigung, ihre Kacheln fliegen durch die Gegend.
Und erst als sie gesagt hat, dafür gehe ich jetzt nicht aus dem Bett,
haben die halt dann so
wie die Eltern, die dann so
trotzig das Zimmer ihrer Kinder aufräumen, haben die Feuerwehr dann gesagt, na gut, dann räumen wir halt jetzt auf. Die Feuerwehr sind schon so ein bisschen wie Eltern, oder? Im Grunde schon. Wenn es brennt, kommen sie, aber sonst wollen sie auch erziehen. Die sagen nicht direkt, ne, ich hol mir das für dich weg. Nicht das Wasser in das brennende Öl. So, ich sehe jetzt bis drei, dann machen sie selber das Feuer aus. Aber es ist auch so ein Ding, das Problem bei der Feuerwehr ist meiner Meinung nach auch, die Feuerwehr kennt keinen subtilen Einsatz. Die haben keine kleinen Autos.
Die haben keine kleinen Martinshörner. Nee, die müssen zu jeder Kleinigkeit immer mit ihrem riesigen Auto kommen, mit der Leiter und stehen dann da rum und denken sich so, das sieht jetzt ein bisschen wie Overkill aus, wir bräuchten eigentlich nur zwei Leute in einem Smart.
Die Fensterfesselten, aber die Feuerwehr hat keinen Smart, die haben nur ihre Kassen und Panzer. Also, das ist eine lustige Beobachtung, aber haben die nicht diese Einsatzwagen, die vorne wegdüsen, diese kleinen? Nee, das ist immer Notarzt oder so, oder Einsatzleiter, aber wenn der, ja, aber nicht jeder Einsatz hat ja einen Einsatzleiter. Der Einsatzleiter kann ja immer sagen, schnapp dich mal mein Einsatzleiter-Auto. Nee, der liegt ja auch im Bett am Samstag Nachmittag. Du hast keine Ahnung, wie ein Einsatzleiter lebt. Du weißt gar nicht von nichts. Und dann kommen die halt immer und alle denken und gucken und gucken. Und dabei stehen die halt nur rum und stellen so einen Bauzaun wieder auf und sagen dann, ja reicht oder passt schon Uwe. Und dann fahren sie wieder. Alle weichen aus, aber es ist einfach nicht viel los. Das war das Beste. Ich war über Weihnachten ja zu Hause, wie man das halt so macht, und dann war da was los, das kann ich euch sagen. In Kam ging nämlich ein Brandstifter umher, der nachts Autos angezündet hat. Und alle meine ehemaligen Schulfreunde sind alle bei der Freiwilligen Feuerwehr Kamen und die haben die Brände gelöscht. Und ich war der nervigste Schulfreund der Städter, der noch nie in seinem Leben eine Glühbirne gewechselt hat, kommt nach Hause und fragt erstmal die Feuerwehrjungs aus, ob sie denn die Schläuche halten durften. Und so ein paar von denen durften so den Schlauch halten und durften löschen. Autos löschen. Das fand ich schon beeindruckend. Das wird ja auch richtig heiß. Und das Und das war wirklich, das war das Thema über ganz Weihnachten, wer macht das? Und da habe ich auch wirklich so Fragen gestellt, wie, habt ihr denn mal die Orte auf der Karte euch angekreuzt? Ja, ob da eine Botschaft hinterlässt. Ob da vielleicht ein großer Penis oder ein Hallo, ihr Freaks oder so entsteht. Und es kamen so Antworten wie, ja, ja, das machen die schon, aber es macht halt die Polizei dann. All die coolen Sachen macht die Polizei. Die Feuerwehr ist eher so die Hausmeister des Staates. Im Grunde schon. Die kümmern sich darum, wenn Wasser läuft, wenn man Feuer ist. Vor allem, es gibt in Deutschland ja unendlich viele Polizeiserien über Kommissare. Es gibt keine einzige Feuerwehrserie. Warum denn nicht? Aber international ja nicht. Selbst da ja nicht. Aber kann man das nicht. Ich meine, du hast ja auch jede Folge einen Fall. So, wer hat das Feuer gelegt? Aber jetzt so eine Feuerbrandstifter-Ermittlung macht auch die Polizei, oder? Ja, macht auch die Polizei. Das ist ja alles. Und dann fiel mir auch, dass die ganzen Fragen, die mir gerade auf der Zunge brennen, die gelöscht werden müssen, eher in Richtung Polizei gehen. Nicht in Richtung. Und dann habe ich noch dreimal gefragt, wer den Schlauch halten konnte, und dann war ich auch zufrieden. Aber das ist schon, ich meine, es gibt super viele Ärzte-Serien, es gibt super viele Polizeiserien, und es gibt keine Feuerwehr-Serien, das kann es doch nicht sein. Feuerwehrmann Sam. Für Kinder oder nicht, gibt es doch. Also ich meine, ist es vom Aufwand vielleicht zu hoch, dass wenn du so ein großes Feuer machst, das zu schwierig ist? Feuer ist teuer, Feuer ist ein Diva. Weil an sich so eine Kommissarserie ist super einfach zu präsentieren. So, weißt du, und deswegen google ich gerne mal, während wir labern, weil wir haben gerade gesagt, es gibt keine Feuerwehrserien. Ich habe auch gesagt, es gibt keine Feuerwehrserien, es gibt zwölf Feuerwehrserien. Wirklich? Feuerwehrmann Sam, Feuer und Flam Feuer und Flamme. Chicago Fire. Chicago Fire seit 2012. 9-1-1 seit 2018. Das hat nicht mehr Bild. Das sind aber alles amerikanische Serien. The Smoke. Grisou, der kleine Drache. Oh, da sehe ich schon sehr viel Potenzial. Oh, scheiße. Weil der wahrscheinlich selber die Feuer verursacht. Wahrscheinlich. Rescue Me, das klingt freiwillige Feuerwehr, das ist auch kein Bild. Das ist einfach Fire Chasers und Notruf California. Warum gibt es keine deutsche Feuerwehr? Ohne Witz, ich glaube, wenn wir, lass uns mal eine... Freiwillige Feuerwehr-Serie machen. Ja, aber wirklich so... Aber keine Comedy, einfach Hardcore-Drama. Ich dachte schon Comedy. Nee, keine Comedy, oder? Aber was ist denn Drama? Ich meine, das Problem ist ja bei einer Kriminalsendung... Wir schauen mal in Grisow rein. Eine Kriminalsendung macht ja immer eine Frage auf, wer hat gemordet. Und das ist spannend, weil am Ende der Folge steht die Antwort. Aber wie machst du es bei der Feuerwehrserie? Wer darf heute den Schlauch halten? Hey Bernd, du warst schon dreimal dabei, den Schlauch zu halten. Jetzt bin ich immer mal dran. Ja, aber du bist noch zu jung, du bist noch zu unerfahren. Es ist halt kein Mysterium so, das ist antiklimaktisch. Du kommst hin, schrecklicher Unfall, überall Benzin und dann schaust du den Leuten dabei zu, wie sie es wegmachen. Ganz ehrlich, beim Bisscrollen von Grisow, der kleine Drache, bin ich ein bisschen enttäuscht. Noch kein Feuer gesehen? Jetzt Feuer. Ein Vogel wird verbrannt. Also auch nicht die klassische Feuerwehrserie, wie man sie erwartet. Ist vielleicht eine Marktlücke für mich. Aber es muss doch, also da muss es doch Leute gegeben haben, die die Idee schon hatten. Falls ihr bei einem Sender arbeitet, bei der ARD oder bei ProSieben, ihr habt bestimmt schon mal Drehbücher für eine Feuerwehrserie bekommen, falls ihr die habt, schickt sie anonym an uns und wir gucken uns an, warum das nicht funktioniert. Warum funktionieren Feuerwehrserien nicht? Das würde mich wirklich interessieren, weil das muss ja einen Grund haben. Ich meine, klar, man kann es von Fernsehen halten, was man will, aber die sind ja auch nicht komplett bescheuert. Eigentlich würde ich gerne mit so einer Formatentwicklung zu reden. Lass uns mal jemanden einladen, weil es muss nichts Lustigeres geben, als die ganze Zeit Formate und Serienideen am Tisch zu haben. Und vor allem Serienideen, die einfach nicht funktionieren. Das darf ich vielleicht nicht verraten, aber ich habe über ein paar Ecken gehört, dass ein großer Streaming-Anbieter, der Serien produziert auf der ganzen Welt, der sehr mittlerweile darauf aus ist, zu expandieren und in vielen Serien lokale Original zu produzieren, mit jedem Land irgendwie klarkommt. In jedem Land kommen irgendwo Serienideen, die die ganze Welt versteht, wo alle was mit anfangen können, wo nicht nur lokal connected werden kann, sondern auch international angeknüpft werden kann. England, Wörsch, Schweden, Dänemark. Ausser aus Japan. Ausser aus Japan, es gibt so eine Comedy, so ein Comedy-Büro, wo jemand die ganze Zeit japanische Formate bekommt, die alle, die niemand versteht.
Niemand hat irgendeine Ahnung bei dem N-Wort.
Also nicht das N-Wort.
Also ein N-Wort.
Niemand hat irgendeine Ahnung, wo man damit anfangen soll, wo die ganze Zeit Formate aus Japan kommen, wo einfach das Ergebnis ein Schulterzucken ist.
Es kann lustig sein, worum geht's, soll das eine Serie sein, ist es ein Factual-Format? Und ich finde das so lustig, dass jedes Land hat noch so, jedes Land hat nicht den Anschluss verloren an das Weltgeschehen, außer Japan. Japan ist Lost, Japan ist eine eigene kleine Welt. Und man versteht es ein bisschen, wenn man diese Japanischen Formate verfolgt, auch die, die ja dann bei dem N-Wort laufen, die sind schon ein bisschen weird. Das stimmt schon. Es sind oft auch so Gameshows. Man hat ja so dieses Klischee von dieser Gameshow, wo ganz viel Text reinfilmet. Und Gifs. Ja, genau. Aber so ist es wohl auch. Es ist so ein bisschen Lost in Translation im Real Life. Man versteht es nicht. Aber ist schon lustig. Deswegen funktioniert da auch nichts.
Da funktioniert nichts und nichts
ausser Japan funktioniert auf der Welt.
Weil es irgendwie so eine eigene kleine Unterhaltungswelt ist.
Aber auf der anderen Seite, so Animes funktionieren
ja total gut.
Ja, da haben sie so ein bisschen gefunden.
Aber alles so mit echten Menschen, sag ich jetzt mal,
funktioniert gar nicht.
Ja.
Wollen wir zur Podcast UFO Deep Dive kommen? Okay, wir gehen ins Deepdive. Der das Podcast-UFO-Deepdive. In der letzten Folge haben wir angesprochen das Intro von Futurama und woher das Lied kommt. Ich habe da eine Referenz gezogen zu einem Lied, das aus dem beliebten Nintendo-Spiel Donkey Konger kommt. Und wir hören mal ganz kurz ins Future-Arma-Ento rein, wie das klingt. So, ich hoffe, das war jetzt nicht lang genug, damit wir irgendwie Copyrights-Rack werden. Nee, du darfst nämlich 19 Sekunden, du darfst ein bisschen länger spielen, glaube ich. Wirklich? Ich glaube, für Podcasts gibt es eh nicht so diese Filter oder so. Hier ist rechtsfeier Raum.
So, und ich habe
einige Zusendungen bekommen, wo
dieses Lied herkommt. Und tatsächlich wurde es oft
gesampelt und oft verwendet.
Zum Beispiel hat jemand mir
geschickt den Intro-Screen
von dem Videospiel
California Games auf dem
Nintendo Entertainment System. Und da ist
folgendes aus dem Jahre 1987. Und da gibt es folgenden Titlescreen mit folgender Intro Musik. Ganz anders, sorry. Was sagst du, ich meine, es ist natürlich eine einfache Tonfolge, die überall vorkommen könnte. Ja, das ist einfach Dominante, Subdominante und Toniker. Das sind drei Tönen, Grundtönen der jeweiligen Akkorde. Das sind natürlich die Grundbausteine eines jeden Hits. Also würdest du sagen Rip-Off, ja oder nein? Nein, kein Rip-Off. Okay, Rip-Off oder Flip-Off? Flip-Off, was davon was ist. Das ist unsere neue Kategorie. Kommen wir zu einem, was auch viele geschrieben haben, und das, glaube ich, war auch das, was ich bei Donkey Kong gespielt habe, ich bin mir nicht sicher. Kann ich doch einmal summen, wie viel Drama geht? Ja, genau. Aber ganz kurz, wie viele Schläge haben wir pro Ton? Haben wir bam bam bam bam bam bam bam bam bam?
Ich glaube nämlich nicht, wir haben nämlich glaube ich nur zwei Schläge.
Warte, wir gehen nochmal ins Futurama-Info.
Es sind nur zwei.
Ja, wir haben nur zwei Schläge, wir haben nur Bam Bam Bam Bam Bam Entertainers. Ist es Nirvana? Das ist ja meine Theorie, dass es Nirvana ist. Bam bam bam bam bam bam bam bam bam bam bam bam bam
warte mal, mach immer die professionelle.
So, und weiter geht's mit dem nächsten, und zwar Louis Louis bam, warte mal, mach immer die.
So, und weiter geht's mit dem nächsten, und zwar Louis Louis von The Kingsman, das kam auch sehr oft, sehr bekannter Song, wir werden wahrscheinlich ab der Stelle wegge-Copyright-Strike und der geht folgendermassen.
Na, es geht nicht hoch! Megasong, Megasong, auch von Mitgliedern, die Pop-Die Version ist mega, aber auch falsch, denn die Musik geht nicht hoch. Es ist nicht ba ba dam, ba ba ba dam, ba ba dam, ba ba dam, ba ba dam, bekannte Tonfolge, kennen wir alle. Wie gesagt, nein. Es ist ja, es ist sozusagen F, B, Gis, Cis. Das sind ja die Töne, über die wir gerade reden. Und was haben wir bei Louis Louis? Bam, bam, bam, bam, bam, bam, bam, bam, bam, das ist nicht richtig. Und wir haben ja drei Schläge, wir haben Future Abba, bam. CB, das ist falsch. Okay, gut. Der nächste Kandidat war, und da bin ich mir hundertprozentig sicher, so achtprozentig sicher, dass das auch der Song von Donkey Konga ist.
Und zwar ist das von The Trox, ähm, Wild Thing.
Ah! Und das werden wir jetzt.
Aber auch das Gleiche, geht auch hoch.
Es ist schon auch sehr ähnlich, aber die sind sich eigentlich ähnlicher als die mit Futurama.
Aber das geht doch auch wieder runter. Das geht doch auch wieder runter.
Das geht runter. Ja, aber Futurama geht doch hoch.
Spiel doch mal Futurama ab.
Okay, wir hören nochmal Futurama.
Ja genau, es geht runter.
Okay, mach nochmal Nirvana. Es ist eher Nirvana als alles andere, sorry. Es geht nämlich runter. Ich habe noch eine Einschickung bekommen, und zwar, ich glaube, von allen der älteste Song, und zwar ich glaube, das kann tatsächlich als direkte Vorlage für das Futurama-Inno sein, weil wir vor allem auch das Glockenspiel haben, diese Glockenschläge, die ja sehr charakteristisch sind für das Futurama-Inno, und zwar kommt das aus dem Jahre 1970, glaube ich, also schon sehr alt.
Und das ist Psyche Rock von Pierre Henry oder Henri, doch, French, okay, Pierre Henri. Nein, nein, das ist Psyche ist schon sehr, sehr nah dran! Das ist es! Aber vielleicht ist das einfach ein Mix von Futurama. Oder ist es auch auf jeden Fall in der Jahreszahl vor dem Erscheinung von Futurama? Ja, das ist so ein bisschen das Problem hier bei dem YouTube-Video. Wir wissen es nicht. Da steht, the tune is inspired by Henry's 1967 Composition Psyche Rock. Also ich glaube, das Video, das wir gerade gehört haben, ist auch inspiriert.
Ich suche jetzt noch mal nach Psyche Rock.
Ja, aber ist nicht alles inspiriert? Ist das nicht die Idee von Kunst, Thais?
So, und ich glaube, das ist die Originalversion von 1967.
Was wir gerade gehört haben, ist ein Remix. Das ist das Original. Okay, das ist schon sehr nah dran. Die Serie für die ganze Familie. Also das ist die Version, so wie ich es verstanden habe, von 1967. Meinst du aber, dass diese ganzen anderen Songs, Louis Louis und Wild Thing, sich auch daran orientieren oder gar nicht? Nein, das sind die Grundpfeile eines jeden Stückes. Wenn du guckst, Mozart sind, weiß nicht, 95 % basieren auf diesem konsonanten Musikstil. Aber es ist natürlich die Frage, das ist ja bei Musik oft die Frage, wo fängt Plagiat an und wo hört einfach Musiktheorie auf? Naja, aber ich sag mal, auch 90% der Punk-Songs haben diese drei Akkorde und deswegen ist da keine Inspiration. Spürbar, ich finde, wenn dann kommt so etwas Stilgebendes wie dieses Glockenspiel zum Beispiel, finde ich, das ist ist es total stilgebend. Und da würde ich sagen, da kann man vielleicht sogar von einem Plagiat, wenn nicht sogar, aber zumindest mal Inspiration sprechen bei Futurama. Also du würdest sagen, dass Pierre-Henri im Jahre 1966 ... Pierre-Henri war für mich am nächsten dran. War am nächsten dran. Okay, dann konnten wir dieses Mysterium ein für alle mal lösen. Vielen Dank, das war der Podcast-Ufo Deep Dive. Die Dive, Dive, Dive, D die Einkaufsstadt. Trotzdem möchte Donalds H&bewusst. Bist unsympathisch, die Einkaufsstadt, trotzdem möchte Donalds H&M daneben usw.
Naja, auf jeden Fall selbstbewusst, wir werden es prüfen.
Wir werden es prüfen auf Leib und Nieren und wünschen euch eine fantastische Woche.
Wir freuen uns auf alle von euch, die wir in Essen treffen.
Und ansonsten macht es gut, haut rein auf eine schöne Woche.
Macht es gut, haut rein auf eine schöne Woche. Und ich wünsche euch alles Gute und Gesundheit.
Ja, danke schön.
Und wir heben ab.